nice I got Gizmo oh right off the bat
Let's Go Gizmo rookie card let's
go usually the lower the number the
harder like number one's always the
hardest one the guy getting attacked by
gremlin from the roof
oh my gosh I don't know another Gizmo
wow he was a popular one back to back oh
there's almost two on there yeah yeah
it's probably drinking yeah watering
something after oh that's the battle oh
vegetable Gremlin let's go he's kind of
scary reminds me of my ex
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jordan Peterson
it's big
there's ladies stuck in what appears to
be jizz ooh
it's a that's a tough card to get some
tough juice wait maybe this was already
open